in our view from the previous approval
so it is recommended for approval thank
you chair uh thank you and i move the
office's recommendation which is as you
understand to approve the vice chair
please second
i'll second that yeah thank you council
com cook members
does anyone wish to debate
don't say we're gonna have an early
night
okay
put it to you members thank you for that
those in favor please
show
those against
any abstentions
that
thank you
thank you councillor wing
that is carried thank you very much
members thank you
moving on to agenda item 4e which is
application for approval of 26 grenville
way broadstairs
speaking in in objection to this
application is a mrs donna king
on behalf of miss linda
thompson
are you there
mr thank you very much you have three
minutes thank you thank you very much
firstly thank you for giving me on
behalf of my parents who reside at 28
grenville way the opportunity to voice
our concerns regarding the proposed rear
extension to number 26.
firstly my parents have made it clear
from the outset that there would be no
objection to a flat roof extension
however what is proposed here is not a
flat roof extension it is a flat top
structure
with sloping sides that
fall short and the main eaves of the
main property by one meter together with
a raised roof light
previously submitted photos already show
that number 26 covers approximately
two-thirds to nearly a half of my
parents kitchen outlook and concerns
have previously been raised regarding
the 40 degree 45 degree rule but no
comment appears to have been made as to
whether this has been addressed or
looked at
the neighbor on the other side number 30
has a number of flat roof extensions
which complement the property and do not
invade others privacy or outlook
the main issue of complaint objection
here is the loss of outlook and natural
light into my parents kitchen
which is a west facing
window the kitchen window is only 74
centimeters high and a meter wide which
provides the only natural light into the
kitchen and the dining
area of the property with a room space
of approximately five metres by three
and a half
the front door leads directly into the
kitchen it's a solid door with two
obscure side glass panels
referring to the report and the policy
qd03
states that development must not lead to
unacceptable living conditions through
the loss of light
outlook or the sense of enclosure and my
parents feel that this
extension would indeed cover those three
points
the natural light will be severely
reduced particularly in the winter
and necessary necessitating the
requirement for lights to be on for long
periods of time my parents are elderly
they're approaching their 80s and they
have concerns with regards to energy
bills anyway so having to have the
lights on the area of the house that
they use significantly is of concern to
them
with regards to the issue on the um the
paragraph around transportation um you
mentioned that the current property
has two bedrooms and there's not going
to be any additional property
additional bedrooms would question that
there has recently been added a an
additional window to the side of the
property that overlooks my parents
property on the on the kitchen side
they already have four vehicles of which
one is parked on the road and one is
usually parked on the grass of the
garden so if additional bedroom is being
created would suggest that maybe someone
else is going to be living there an
additional transport would be needed
i would stress again we have no
objection to a flat roof extension but
the proposal here is not that and the
policy
qdqd03 will appear to have been
contravened to the lack of light our
outlook and the sense of enclosure
i would add my comments but i would add
to my end my comments by adding that
this whole business had a significant
impact on the health the mental and
physical health of my parents who i say
are in there approaching their 80s this
was their forever home and the stress
has not been good for them thank you
again for taking the time to listen to
our comments and trust you will take
these on board when reviewing the
proposal thank you
thank you very much mrs king
when i asked the planner officer to
outline this application which i believe
is emma
please
thank you chairman uh this is the
application site um outlined in red here
so the number 26 grenville way you can
see the staggered layout of the
properties
this is an aerial view of the property
so this is the application site here so
the proposal is for an extension in this
location here
and then this is a view and looking
towards the site so this is um the
property here so it's this application
site here and this is the neighboring
property number 28 granville way who
have concerns regarding the impacts on
their side windows you can see
in this image these are the windows i've
just been referred to so there's a
door a window serving a kitchen area in
this location here
and then another window
in this location here and here which are
serving um the bathroom and wc can i
just correct you there that window you
point
i can't let you speak again i'm sorry
it wasn't the window to the bathroom
um so this is the front of the property
taken from granville way so the proposal
includes a front extension in this
location here that's set back behind the
existing
garage and would be flat roof
and this is taken from the neighbor's
property so we've been inside the rear
garden of the neighbouring property and
so this is looking towards the
application site which is in this
location here
so you can see the existing boundary
treatment between the properties
this is looking towards the side
elevation of the application sites you
can see the existing windows and the
existing roof form
and this is the existing windows within
the neighboring property looking sorry
within the application property looking
towards the neighbouring property this
is taken from inside the neighbouring
property looking out so this is the
kitchen window and door
where concern is raised regarding the
impact to light and outlook from this
window
so you can see the existing building in
this location here and the proposal is
for an extension that extends out from
the rear of this property at the same
ease level
and following that roof pitch
and this is taken from inside the
kitchen looking again towards the
application site so again you can see
this is the area of concern
where the extension would be in this
location here and the impact that would
have on light to this room
the kitchen
does contain some seating space so we
have considered it to be a habitable
room and have considered the application
on that basis
this is just taken again from the
neighbouring site looking um towards the
rear of the garden so again just showing
the boundary treatment between the plots
so this is the block plan showing the
proposal so to the front of the site is
a single story flat roof extension and
then behind the existing garage is a
again another small extension this
location here and this location to the
rear of the site which is a 4.5 meter
deep
extension which was originally pitched
roof but has been amended as you'll see
in the plans in a moment and again these
are the this is the neighboring property
to which um there's concern regarding
from the from the neighbour regarding
impact to their light and outlook from a
kitchen window that's in this location
here
so this is the existing front elevation
of number 26 grand grenville way and you
can see this is the garage at the front
and they've got a small um porch at the
moment and this is the proposed
extension so be similar in appearance to
the existing garage follow the same roof
line um bricks to match the existing
property and this exception would be set
back behind the garage and therefore
there's no real concern raised with the
impact on the carriage of the area
this is the existing side elevation
that
faces the neighboring property and this
is a proposed elevation so
as you can see this is the rear
extension
originally the application came in with
the extension following the ridgeline of
the existing property amended plans were
sought during the application um
we didn't look at whether a flat roof
was possible but the applicant has put
forward this plan which looks at a
reduced ridge line so this element here
is now a flat roof um with a so the ease
line is following through these lines at
2.25 meters
and then this reduced ridge line is
now 3.8 meters so it's been reduced from
4.8 which was at this level here
and you can see there's no
windows within the side elevation facing
the neighbouring property
this is the existing elevation facing
number 24 grenville way and this is the
proposed elevation so again you can see
the rear extension in this location here
so there is a window within the rear
elevation but there are some existing
windows already within that side
elevation it's not considered that this
this window in this location would have
any additional
impact on privacy when compared to the
existing windows are already facing
number 24.
there's already also a extension
proposed in this location here which is
just the rear of the existing garage and
as you can see it's just of a similar
design and height to the existing garage
and it's not considered that this would
result in any concerns
this is the existing rear elevation and
this is now the proposed so you can see
originally the application had the ridge
line at this point here this now been
dropped by the meter to
attempt to reduce the impact on the
neighboring property and now there's a
flat roof at this point here
again in terms of materials you can see
its materials to match and following the
existing
roof line of the existing property
and then these are the floor plans so
the floor plan on the left is the
existing floor plan you can see the
garage
in this location here
so the proposal is for this small
extension to the rear of the garage
and then this front extension that
projects out um the front extension is
2.95 metres deep at a height of 2.5
meters but as you can see it's set back
beyond the front elevation of the garage
so there's limited limited concern on
the amenities of the area in terms of
the neighbor impact you can see there's
a distance to the neighboring property
so again no
impact regarding
lighter outlet from that extension
this is the extension to the rear so
this is the the area that's where
there's some concern
um again you can see the side window
that face is number 24 and you can see
the distance to the boundary of number
24 which is three meters and you can see
the distance to the boundary with number
28
and then this is the section plan just
showing the rear extension
and the existing roof plan and proposed
roof plan
so the the main concerns are to do with
the impact on the living conditions of
um number 28 so as you can see there's a
distance of
three
meters no sorry 4.5 meters even
between the proposed extension and the
side elevation of the neighbouring
property
so whilst there is
a habitable room window in this location
here it is considered the given the
distance of 4.5 metres
given the reduced height of the ridge
level um and the ease level of the
property which is only slightly above
the fence line is not considered that
this would result in significant impact
to the light and outlet from this window
is appreciated there would be some
impact but it's not considered
significant enough to warrant the
refusal of the application in terms of
the remaining two windows they're not
serving habitual rooms so there's no
concern regarding the impact on these
windows so the application is currently
recommended for approval um thank you
chairman
uh thank you
i move that the office office's
recommendation is adopted the vice chair
please second oh second nature council
common cook members
do you wish to comment
council robin
yeah i think we should comment on it
chair
and certainly the
design
quite happy with that i can't see any
issues with the front
or rear or
rear rear extension the small one is
neither here nor there obviously the
major issue is on is on the residence at
number 28
um i suppose
the question posed is um
the rooms that are affected can you just
tell can you just go back over it again
please as to the two rooms that that are
affected and
the
i know whether you've worked out the
tight the times of day that the the sun
comes over from the east
um
as to how long they would be
any particular light would be shut out
so
this is the side elevation of the
neighboring property so this is the
kitchen window and door in this location
here
um this i believe is the bathroom um
i thought this was i mean we have
visited the site and i thought we were
told this by the neighbour but we've got
this down as a wc but it may well be
that that's the secondary window to this
room here so in which case again the
impact on this window wouldn't be
of a huge concern because they already
have rear windows serving that room if
that is a habitable room so the main
issue really is the impact on this
kitchen
um and
just to go back to the photo so this is
the view from inside the kitchen
and this view here
so
as you can see the extension would
follow this ridge this is level so it's
only slightly above the fence line and
then the roof would hip away from the
neighbor
so the fact that the roof is hipping
away
means it would have limited impact and
really it's the it's this impact of the
wall up to each level that is is going
to be resulting in impact to to the to
the light of that property but given
that small distance from the fence up to
that ease level
it's not really considered that's a
significant impact so i'll just go back
to the point here so in terms of this
plan as you can see north is above so in
terms of light
coming through light would be starting
the sun on the right hand side and
falling through along here so
at this point there's still no impact so
it's only at this point here that there
would be some loss of light from the sun
that's facing towards the neighboring
property and the reduction in that
height means that there would be
obviously less impact compared to the
original plans
so it's not considered
given that distance because quite often
you'd have a side window with maybe only
one meter or two meters to the boundary
this is a 4.5 meter distance so it's
considered with that distance and then
the drop in height which would allow for
more sun to get through to that side
elevation
we consider that the impact is
acceptable
thank you
everybody understands the the light
the loss of um blue light or blue sky if
you want and that's probably what
they're going to lose the blue sky
effect um
my question is if it was a flat roof how
much lower would it be than the pitched
roof that it's at
roughly are we talking a meter are we
talking two meters
because that could make a dramatic
difference because the blue sky appeals
amazing for some people and you know
when trees are cut and things like that
that that is the difference it makes for
people to have the blue sky blue sky out
their window and they may lose that and
that's that is in a way quite sad so i'm
just curious to know what the difference
is if it wouldn't make much difference
it's neither here nor there thank you
chair
um so the distance to eaves is currently
2.25 and the distance to the ridge as
amended is 3.8 so there's currently a
distance of a
difference of 1.65 metres between the
two obviously with a flat roof that will
be higher than the eave level but we're
basically talking a bit more than a
meter difference between a flat roof and
the
pitch roof that we currently have
thank you uh council grand
thank you
i would like to go back to the view from
the the kitchen window again because
councillor hart has actually just put me
to the post a little bit because
that was pretty much
where i was looking at and thinking if i
was living there i'm going to lose that
bit of blue sky
and
again if that was a flat roof which um
the uh
coupling 28 are saying
would be acceptable then there is very
limited loss of blue sky but if i can
it's hard to do all the imagination here
but
it's going to be almost no blue sky at
all they're losing about
a third to a half with a flat roof but
losing almost all of it
i guess it partly it depends on the
angle the photographs are taken from and
that's the bit i wanted to come back to
because you're just going to have to
stand right up against the window to get
your blue sky
i'll i'll move on to come back to uh
castle austin i just wanted to to second
what uh council clinton said that
looking at those photos it concerns me
greatly that that is going to block out
most of that blue sky view
and this is a habitable room
uh a
a
single story flat rift extension would
be a totally different matter i think
thank you um
bear with me if you would consider
everything
yeah i find this quite difficult one to
be honest with you because
um
i can see the argument um
for the neighbours right to develop and
i can see
the impacts upon the res these residents
i think perhaps what that photograph
doesn't do is give you a proper sense of
the separation distance between the two
buildings
um which i think was four and a half
meters i mean it looks as if that fence
is right up against the window and then
the building on the other side is quite
close i have to say on balance i think
i'm against it because i think that
you're going to lose the view from that
window and arguing about the ridge
height and it's and it's stepping away
doesn't really um
override the fact that what they're
going to be looking at is a wall and a
sloping roof
so i think it is a difficult one and
he's a marginal call but i think i'm my
sympathies are with the neighbours and
i'm likely to vote against it
cut some more yes thank you chair um
could you uh the officers please explain
why
um they've gone for the ridge effect
if it's on the ground floor what what's
above that from the ceiling height to
that ridge
um is it a voltage ceiling or
um because that's not quite clear
that's my first question thank you
do you have another one
this is the uh section plan showing
inside the building so yes it is a
raised ceiling so that's it's there's no
accommodation at first for a level it's
just a high ceiling
with um a roof light basically to get
light into that space
thank you um yeah i could see the roof
light from the rear elevation what
appeared to be
i'm quite in agreeance with council
everett and some of the other members
i think it's going to be a massive
impact on the neighbour for that window
and that light
and i don't feel comfortable with that
as
a flat roof would not change the outlook
greatly because it's a large extension
anyway so they're still going to have a
large area to utilize so i i wouldn't be
in favor of this myself thank you chair
thank you accounts right um very much
the same as everybody else has said um
to say that you don't think that the
planning officer doesn't think the loss
of light is going to impact
it will make that it will make that that
room really dark
and that they will they'll lose all
their natural light
which does worry me because in you know
in these times it means that they're
going to have to most of the time
they're going to have to turn a light on
so that they can actually have
a decent place to step to be
so i won't be supporting this
application
thank you councillor alban we should
come back yeah thank you chair um i'm
also in agreement but um i think
for us if the uh if the applicant
uh would come back with a flat roof
um
at that level that will
considerably
help the issue for the applicant
all right i hope you don't mind a bit of
advice here members as usual
it's obvious that um
members have concerns about the design
it's possibly could be put to you and mr
livingston come on to this one about
um
deferring it but i'll let
uh mrs lemmons explain
um so obviously i appreciate the debate
is still ongoing sometimes haven't made
up their mind fully but obviously we've
had the majority of members raising
points of concern about the same issue
in terms of
the ability of members to seek
amendments to the proposal obviously at
the moment if the motion is voted on it
would be potentially if it's voted down
then an alternative motion could be put
forward
to defer four officers seek amendments
for it to be altered to a flat roof
design
i do think it's important to note though
that the flat roof design if the
applicant is agreeable
would not necessarily be
at the level of the eaves height of the
structure that you can see which is 2.25
i think it was isn't it so it may be a
little bit higher than that but it would
obviously give members an eye an option
to have a look at the impact for a flat
roof design which would appear to deal
with a number of concerns that have been
have been raised so
if if the chair is so minded to withdraw
the motion with the agreement of um the
the vice chair
then if a member wished to put forward
an alternative motion to seek those
amendments as as stated then that could
potentially progress
uh thank you you and i think that does
make sense listen to comments from
members
so i will do that i put it
withdraw this motion like device shared
please second
oh secondary thank you uh council colin
cook
and could i have a member please
counsellor everett
i propose that the um
the application is deferred for officers
to have discussions with the applicant
about the potential for a flat roof
proposal
thank you very much for that councillor
everett could i have a second to please
councillor auburn uh members do you
agree
yes
sorry members we will have to vote on
that motion but also just wanted to
clarify in terms of that motion that it
would come back to members just to make
it absolutely clear and so
that's the voucher
that's my fault
okay thank you i'll come back to your
sales members do you agree on that
motion that's been put forward by cancer
every
that is unanimous thank you
uh moving going on to agenda item 4g
which is an application for refusal of 7
11
excuse me and 15 westlift terrace
mentions ramsgate uh speaking in favor
of the application is mr andrew evans mr
evans are you there
no um mr rigdon's here in his place he's
in he's on holiday oh very nice too but
mr written you wish to speak and again
you have three minutes thank you thank
you thank you chair on behalf of the
applicant i would like to read
the following statement for both
applications relating to this
dilapidated and partially unused
building
members may be aware that parts of the
landmark building have fallen into a
serious state of disrepair the roof has
failed and years of water ingress has
caused a serious amount of damage to the
internal fabric
windows have rotted repeated break-ins
and theft of extraordinary historic
features like fireplaces have taken
place
the current owner has already shown his
intent by investing heavily in the
remedial works paying particular
attention
to holistic building status as the
photographs provided clearly demonstrate
our statement will cover the most
contentious points of the proposals
raised by the planning and conservation
officers
the application is a resubmission
following refusal of an application for
the same proposals
negotiations and discussions during the
first application were non-existent
despite our efforts to communicate with
the planning and conservation officers
whilst every attempt was made to
negotiate a way forward to a mutually
acceptable proposal the planning
officers were not willing to work with
us
retrospective approval is sought for the
boiler flues to the front elevation
along with addition of boiler flues of
third floor level to the rear elevation
the conservation officer incorrectly
states in her comments that the boiler
flues to the front
are to serve the ensuites and describe
them as
upvc material
the boiler flues to the front elevation
are existing and have since been
decorated to match the external facade
to reduce impact on the listed building
any additional flues required to the
third floor have been proposed to the
rear elevation to reduce impact upon the
street scene
it is proposed all flues are decorated
to match the external facade and will
not be pvc but powder coated still as
standard
the construction of the ensuites has
been opposed by both planning and
conservation officers
president has been provided for both 2
and 22 westcliff terrace mansions where
subdivision of rooms has previously been
approved to provide ensuites
our current proposals
have not been accepted
the proposed layout within and on within
an ensuite for the master bedrooms does
not uncomfortably divide the existing
bathrooms
as both meet
recommended space standards
the proposed balustrade repairs to the
rear of the building will be of concrete
lintels and reinforced render finish
to provide a more robust structure
for the top rail of the balustrade the
concrete lintels will also be
less affected by differential movement
and moisture content compared to
brickwork
and will prevent cracking to the render
this alternative method will prolong the
life of the balustrade whilst remain in
keeping with the appearance of the
existing features
in summary the applicant is investing
heavily in updating and preserving this
listed building
it is considered that proposed work will
not cause harm but bring life to the
designated heritage asset securing its
optimum viable use thank you
uh thank you mr egton call upon
councillor brenda rogers who is speaking
under 20.1
thank you chairman and members
this beautiful building has suffered
years of neglect over a long period of
time and has become a dumping ground for
large items of rubbish
this is actually improving with work
being done there
i visited this property with an open
mind but it has been very tastefully
refurbished to a very high standard
other parts of this building already
have flus and outside entry systems
as there are pillars to the side of the
front doors i failed to see where entry
systems would be placed if not on the
door
the parts of the balustrade that have
been repaired are admittedly
constructed with different materials but
so well done and made to last they fit
in perfectly with the rest of it
paragraph 130 on the mppf
states that decisions should ensure that
developments will function well add to
the overall quality of the area and are
visually attractive i believe this
application ticks these boxes
in my view all the works that have been
done enhance the look of this building
and also the street scene it's a
pleasure to see these improvements after
years of decay and if you're any any
doubt whatsoever i urge you to have a
site visit thank you
thank you counselor rogers um
call upon and about to give the report
yeah thank you chair
so this is the application site outlined
in red it's flat
7 11 and 15
west cliff terrace mansions in ramsgate
this is an aerial view so it's these
middle
units in this picture here
we have another view of the application
site
and again it's we're looking at the
units in the middle here
it's as you can see it is a substantial
building it's four stories in height
it's grade two listed and within the peg
well conservation area
so
the application is a full application
for planning permission for
retrospective replacement of a basement
window
the replacement and repair of
balustrading to the rear
an intercom system to the front of the
building
within the doors
boiler flues to the front and rear and
replacement roof lights
so this is the existing front elevation
and you can note at the basement level
here that in the middle there is a
window that looks different to the
others and looks out of place
and this is the window that's
been replaced so you can see the
existing window as you saw in the
elevation there to the left hand side
this is the window that's been inserted
and it's single glazed and timber and
officers do consider this is an
acceptable replacement which enhances
the look and appearance of the building
and this is a photograph of that window
in situ
sorry
um
as has been mentioned there are a number
of
boiler flues and flues that are
proposed or existing on the building
this is the existing building
um front elevation and i
cannot pick out any of the flues on this
building but we'll look at the proposed
sorry this is a photograph actually
showing the internal arrangements
um
and the flues we were understood when we
met on when officers were outside were
to serve the on suites bedrooms
and various suffer
boiler locations in kitchens and things
so it isn't actually very clear but
that's why
we are assuming there's such a number of
proposed flues
so this is a
the proposed front elevation
and you can see a number of dots
around the building which are the
proposed boiler flues
this is zooming in again so you can see
one side
of it so you can see a number here of
the boiler flues
and this is the other side again there
are a number of fluids that can be seen
there
this is the existing rear elevation
which doesn't have any flues
and this is the proposed and you can see
at the top floor here
um free flows across
excuse me there are 8 um
flues
for the front elevation and free to the
rear elevation
officers have concerns about the number
of the flues on the
both the front and rear elevation but
particularly to the front elevation
where they are
visually
haphazardly located
and do not bear
sort of resemblance to the simple form
of the building
and they are dotted around haphazardly
and as officers do have concerns yes
that they are linked to the introduction
of ensuites
and other things and they do not think
it is sufficient that they could be
covered up and painted
that would reduce the impact of the harm
to the listed building
so this is a photograph
of the front elevation
and that's enough for photograph there
and you can see
some of the flues
are there
so the application also which has been
mentioned proposes a replacement or
repair of some balustrading to the rear
when this is looked at a ground
the balustrading is at ground floor
level when looked at from
for the occupants of westcliff terrace
mansions but it's a higher level
essentially almost firstful level when
viewed from the grassed area behind
so this is a plan showing
the balustrading and you can see there
are elements missing
here
but if we zoom in
this on the left is the existing
balustrade construction and peer
construction
and you'll see it's slightly angled
and this is the proposed
construction
and the pier as well and you will see
that it's not as angled and defined as
the existing
balustrading and pier construction
particularly at the capping
[Music]
and so we've got some pictures of it
this is the existing
balustrading and capping where it's not
been repaired
this is an example
of it
where it's been repaired
it's
not completely finished as you've seen
from the detailing
shown on the plan so there would be
capping here but you can note it is a
lower level and
as i understand it this
balustrading capping of the balustrading
is completed and doesn't have that
defined angle
this as you can see is showing
a longer piece of the balustrading so
you can see this bit here which hasn't
been repaired and you can see
this
new bit here and it is slightly lower
down so you do get a distinction in
levels and this is the
difference in levels which i mentioned
earlier
this is looking from west cliff terrace
mansion so it's a sort of a ground floor
level but you can see the area beyond is
lower in level so it's it's higher up
and you get a more
it's more visible from that area
and again this is just another view of
the balustrading
and the pier here and as i say officers
have concerns
that it doesn't have the quality of
finish
and the definition that the original
balustrading and capping had
and there is no real justification being
put forward that we feel
to justify why there is a change in
material and why it cannot be
constructed in the same materials
as the original balustrading and capping
the applicants advise that the original
materials have failed over time and
have basically just not stood the test
of time
but it is notice that we consider it to
be pretty much the original balustrading
so it's been in place for approximately
150
odd years so
you know you give it some
benefit that it stood quite a long time
on site and we do think it can be
repaired using original materials
so moving on another
item that's been mentioned is the doors
entry system
the applicants argue it's an assist
essential element of the scheme and it
um and it's helpful for modern living
where people can obviously buzz in
um visitors etc and the other doors in
the wider terrace have such systems
um
these are
the other doors have placed them
to the side because they don't have the
original pillars which as you can see
are retained here and you can see it
from
the picture here so in this instance
the the actual intercom system is placed
on the wooden door itself which is a
original door and feature of the
listed building
so officers have concerns
about the impact of that and the visual
intrusion and the harm to the integrity
of the building
and the its simple historic
proportions we do understand it is
convenient for residents of these sorts
of units to be able to buzz in
their visitors
etc but we do not consider it to be an
essential part of
a building of this nature
and it's not considered the convenience
to residents
or we would outweigh the harm to the
listed building because that would be a
private benefit to those residents and
not a public benefit
so there is a picture here of the door
one of the doors with the intercom
in place
and as you can see we do consider it
alter the proportions of that door
but we do understand it cannot be placed
where others have placed their intercom
sisters because it does retain the
pillars which is
a good
good thing to have been retained
the last replacement is the replacement
of existing roof lights
with new aluminium roof lights
this bottom plan here is the existing
roof plan and you can see here a number
of
roof lights shown
and it's
slightly harder to see here but this is
third floor plan and through the middle
of this plan you can see dotted lines
which are the roof lights above
and they are essentially in the same
place as they are in the same places
existing roof lights
this is the plan of the roof lights that
will will be there replaced
and this is just a picture of the roof
light
and there's no real objection in
principle to that
replacement
so
to conclude there are no there is not
considered to be any impact from the
proposed development on
for example living conditions or highway
safety or other
impacts
but it is considered that there is
a
significant harm to
the listed building and heritage assets
of the wider conservation area
it is considered to be less than
substantial so it is weighing it up as
we are instructed to do by the policy
the paragraphs and guidance and the mppf
um about whether
prior there is public benefits that
outweigh that harm
it is not considered by officers that
there is that public benefit there are
private benefits and they are
acknowledged
and so the officer recommendation is for
refusal thank you chair uh thank you
annabelle before i move the officer's
recommendation i'm going to bring in mr
livingston now planning applications
manager
ian
thanks thank you chair i just want to
come in uh if possible about the
balustrading um just because um i just
want to just clarify something for
members sorry bear with me i'll just
cast my screen now to the
to the screen so it works um
so
just to clarify the point with regards
to what's being proposed um
as as um annabelle mentioned this is
unfinished in terms of what's being
proposed um if we go back to the image
here you can see uh on the left hand
side you've got the existing ballista
australian construction
which shows that effectively what you've
got is you've got brickwork above the
balustrading and then you've got roof
tiles internally that's then all
effectively capped by the sand and
cement
what's being proposed is a as mentioned
by the uh the applicant's representative
is a change in the way that it's
constructed so that it's actually
reinforced with with chicken wire mesh
and effectively sort of built up on a
concrete lintel and you've just seen
that concrete lentil in the image that i
showed you
the concern here is obviously as
mentioned the the prominence of this set
of balustrading in the conservation area
the wider conservation area um and
obviously the setting of the listed
building and part of that is about
making sure that um the historic methods
of
so that it entirely matches both in
material and in appearance
everything that's there and whilst
obviously the appearance has been shown
on the plan
that would be proposed
would would match that it's obviously
the construction although as mentioned
in the report there are some concerns
about the levels whether or not they
would precisely match what's there at
the moment
from what has been constructed on site
so i just wanted to clarify that this
isn't finished it's proposed to build up
the
that lentil that's there on site
thank you chap
thank you anne
therefore i move the officer's
recommendation is adopted could the vice
chair please second
i second that's you thank you
members cancer auburn
yes thank you chair um
i went and had a look at this on monday
and because i wanted to see it
see what dastardly acts
have been
committed to this uh
very large and substantial building and
terrace
um i have to say that
if you go and walk in along the front
there
in in front of the building um and you
look up
the
the boiler flues that that we're talking
about
merge very well
with the building they have been painted
the same
color and they match in quite well
you know we are in 2022 and is an
existing boiler boiler flu so you need
some heating in these places because
they are cold
uh
and also um
in relation to uh
the other issues
uh
especially in relation to the uh
to the buzzers for what for want of a
better word and as has been mentioned by
the officer when you go along there
there are these other ones which are
protruding
quite substantially out from the
building although they're not on the
door that is a flat plate against the
door
now which can be removed at
any time
should it should just get approved or
refused or whatever
for me
you got this very large substantial
building and these things are absolutely
minor and have no effect whatsoever on
the on this
effectively beautiful
listed terrace
um
the work that i've seen on the front
elevation looks outstanding
uh it's been done to a very high
standard
so having a look at that so i went
outside again of course from what you
can't see there is it's all tree-lined
on the front
behind behind the main uh
behind the boundary wall
on the front and there is a little
roadway that goes in between the front
boundary and
the building
so there is no effect
on the street scene in my opinion
whatsoever
now from then i had to clamber around
the back because you can't get access to
the back unless you go right the way
around
so i went all the way around
to out to have a look at this
balustrade and as has been pointed out
it's not finished
by any means
um
i understand
uh that it was probably the
developer was told to stop work on it i
guess
when the officers went around
and obviously that is the state that it
was left in
when they were told to stop work that's
what i'm surmising
now the officers have already said in
relation to other stuff the window the
um the roof lights
are okay
and what we're talking about here are
these minor very minor issues
now if
you refuse the minor if you refuse the
minor issues
then you refuse the whole thing
you're refusing everything
so
that's the decision that we have to take
personally
i see no harm to the listed structure
because of its size
these are very small items and they do
not detract
from the statue of the listed building
and if i can make one more if i can make
one more issue chair
if member if if the officers can show us
the rear elevation
of the building
and when and when you look at this part
in the middle which which you can see
now if you go because i walked along
here and if you go to the about halfway
down
uh the next uh the end block
at two levels there are there were
balconies
and either we've allowed or overlooked
they put in sliding
sliding either upvc or aluminium sliding
doors
within this building that's a major
alteration
to so if anything we should have taken
action against that or if we've approved
it
why are we why are we refusing this so i
do have an issue with their chair so
if the officers can answer that i would
very very grateful thank you
uh thank you very much for that council
album and i'm going to bring back
um mr levinson uh thank you thank you
just to pick up that last point on the
uh alterations that you've mentioned
that's is it first floor sorry council
organ was it first floor of of the the
one of the neighboring properties um i
must admit i i'm not aware of that i
don't know whether or not that uh has
listed building content from the way
you've described it i very much doubt
it's got a list of building consent um
and that is something that obviously we
we could investigate um and see or maybe
it's previously been investigated by the
enforcement section i'm not sure um
obviously it's about considering what's
in front of members and council organs
made that quite clear i do just want to
clarify one point about the difference
between this application and the next
application
because of the next application is a
listed building consent application so
it's particularly about the listed
building itself
this application the consideration is
about the setting of the listed building
and the impact on the conservation area
and the wider character of the area so
that's the differentiation there but i
do pick up obviously the points that
council auburn you've just made there
thank you thank you i'll come back chair
yes yeah thank you chair um so
the concern that i now have
chair is that when our officers went on
site to have a look at this application
i mean i spotted it i spotted these
aluminium sliding doors in about two
seconds flat and i'm surprised that our
officers didn't spot that and didn't
look to see whether that got consent
thank you chair
thank you council auburn council heart
thank you chair as you know i'm usually
vocal on these sort of things um
we as i do agree totally with council
auburn i think we have to have
a little bit of sense about all of this
what do the council want if they don't
want a flat
box or a flat
sheet on a door to let people into a
property do they want a big stand out
the front with a big box on it that they
can then press a button what is the
alternative they're asking for i mean i
just think
it's nice to have properties brought
back into use and be habitable for
people of the area just because they've
got a little little plaque on the front
of steve quite rightly says that can be
removed if necessary um
all of these flues we've got to have
rooms that are usable and have to have
flus and i
personally i totally agree with with
with councillor auburn with regards to
balustrade i am assuming the same as him
that work was stopped so it isn't
finished because it does look appalling
and i am sure that the builder will put
that right but that needs to be
clarified please um
and
one assumes that they are going to end
up at the same height because they're
going to put coping stones on top of the
that
concrete plinth um but
until you can confirm that i just think
that we'll just get penickity and i
think that's wrong and i think we should
actually be trying to make these houses
habitable for the future thank you
thank you that's the car that's uh
austin
thank you chair can i um point out to
members the um left-hand end of this
terrace i'm very familiar with this
terrace i walk there very regularly
there is a an area there on that on the
plan we just saw
could we go back to that
on there on the left-hand end there we
have um
uh flats which are actually come right
out
so they they don't have balconies they
don't have the the all the structure so
something again
following on from what councilor alvin
has pointed out something has either
been permitted or done without
permission there that completely ruins
the um symmetry of this building already
from the rear
um
these
developers have done a splendid job on
what was a virtually derelict building i
am the last to say
let's go ahead and allow x y and z
because we've allowed a b and c before
but frankly i live close to wellington
crescent in in ramsgate which is
bristling with satellite dishes and all
sorts of stuff and it could be an
immaculate georgian terrace like in bath
but it's not because it's infallid i'm i
am
unhappy with the look of some of the
buzzers and this kind of thing i agree
with the officers on that but frankly we
have to live with the times and
certainly the flues are almost invisible
and and as katherine has pointed out the
whole
frontage is shrouded by trees the effect
on the conservation area has got to be
virtually nil
thank you thank you councillor austin
cascrinton
thank you yes i think we're getting a
bit of a theme here actually because um
some of what i'm my thinking is has
already been said
as councillor alban has said um this
terrace is actually not visible from the
road i feel that we actually have five
elements here two of which officers are
actually quite happy to approve
the only one that i have any
potential concern with is the
balustrading but
as we've already seen that's not yet
complete so there is the scope to ensure
that that that can be done um in an
appropriate manner
um
we do need entry
um
ways of alerting people in flats you i
know those doors you can't hammer on
them
my paid job is as a door knocker
so i do appreciate
[Music]
i do appreciate going to flats where
there are doorbells um so i would
definitely support them having some kind
of access if you don't mind um but yes i
think broadly um i would be happy to
support this application very much as
it's already been said um
overall thank you
thank you constantine i've come back to
you about that door knocking okay
thank you uh
right any other members wish to comment
okay i'm going to put this to you
members the officer's recommendation is
for refusal
uh which you've heard the report
those in favor of officers refusal
please show
those against
any abstentions
one abstention
that has
fallen
so can you bear with me just one moment
please and like i'll come back to you
more for a proposition
as usual i'm going to hand over to mr
livingston because he's prepared for
things
um thank you councillor tomlinson um the
i've seen members of outlined that they
don't consider that the works
um
it's kind of two different points though
one is that
um members don't consider the works harm
the setting the list of building or the
or impact on the conservation area so
effectively the works preserve
the impact on the character appearance
the area
um obviously some members have
considered that actually the overall
span of the works
in total preserve the the the character
appearance the area so
a motion that if the chair was minded to
propose would be for
approval
as members consider the works
would not affect the listed building and
the peg oil conservation area
and this is quite important subject to
safeguarding conditions because as
you've seen the works have not been
complete and so we would need to ensure
that the works in the external works and
that's obviously all we're talking about
the external works of this in this
application adhere to safeguarding
conditions
picture
thank you and if members
are happy what you've heard there i
would like a proposal for that motion to
put that motion to you
counselor moore uh second and please
count to shrub
uh those in what favor
they've got to vote on it again
okay
i'm gonna ask you to vote on that motion
once again please so those in favor
anyone against
abstraction extensions
that is carried thank you for that
members
move over to annabelle now for the which
is public speaking i think
yes we have here application again which
is for a gender item for h which is for
refusal once again 11 17 11 15 west
terrace mansions
um also i'm going to ask mr ridden to
comment
were you were you prepared for that mr
rigdon
i don't want to read the statement
no fair comment fair comment
required i'm sorry
so i understand don't worry please don't
worry i've got a i'm sure you know i've
got a running list of here of names and
everything else so
i won't embarrass you so uh i will come
therefore to um
uh councillor brenda rogers speaking
under 20.1
if you wish to speak council rogers
thank you chairman of members
again i refer to the high standard of
renovation done on this building i was
invited into another flat owned by an
elderly couple
one of the several flats
deterioration has taken place over many
years water coming in through the
ceiling in a very bad state of repair
there is absolutely no comparison with
the words that with the works that have
been done by the applicants
yes they've been on added but tastefully
done and they don't detract from the
overall look
yes there are traditional cupboards and
stores but a necessary addition even the
skirting boards have been replaced with
the same design as the originals
and again i will ask if members wish to
see it have a site visit but uh
i have no doubt whatsoever that it's
been beautifully done thank you
thank you councillor rogers
wright will ask the planet officer which
once again i believe is unbelievable to
give a report please
yeah thanks chair
so again this is as we say the listed
building application associated with the
full application we've just uh
considered
the applications are outlined in red
and again a view
of the application site
so
the listed building consent is sought
for all the items covered in the full
application we've just looked at plus
two additional items
that are
within the internal
uh
eternal internal
interior of the flats excuse me so that
is the installation of fireplaces and
subdivision of existing bathrooms to
create family bathrooms and ensuites
so this is existing first and second
floor plans so you can see
the first floor on the second floor as
you go up each floor
they remain the same the spacing just
carries on
um
on each floor
and you can see it follows through onto
the third floor as existing here and
then we have the roof planners existing
at the bottom there
so
this is
the first sorry the first and second
floor
and onto the right of the image you can
see a variety of fireplaces
and the purple
notation which you can see
in some areas here are where the
fireplaces are going so you've got three
different types
so some are for the lounge you've got a
bedroom fireplace and a kitchen
bedroom fireplace
and they will be um
put in places
where fireplaces did exist
and some have been lost and that's an
example of one of the fireplaces that
has been installed
and officers do consider the fireplaces
are acceptable and do enhance and
preserve
um
the actual historic
features of the building
so again looking again at the first and
second floor plans
we're going to draw a look at the
addition of the ensuites and whether
that is acceptable within the listed
building
so essentially what you have
is a subdivision
on all
floors of this
element here which was an open space so
it was a bathroom this whole area
and they've been subdivided to create
the family bathroom
and
an
ensuite bathroom to the main bedroom
so
sorry bear with me
so
the former bathroom was a good site with
natural light and
ventilation the subdivision of the
bathrooms has resulted in fairly small
bathrooms
that whilst they are adequate in size
would not have
are an uncomfortable and untraditional
arrangement which detracts from the
historic understanding of the original
room layout and we've seen before that
they were open spaces and they followed
through on every floor
um
also the proposal also
involves a doorway being formed within
original internal wall which results in
harm and loss of his historic fabric and
you'll see that at each level
the alterations so the creation of
another bathroom ensuite also involves
the need for further waste and services
to be installed and we've seen the
flues etc
coming out
to serve the ensuites and the rear
elevation in the previous application
the pre the justification for provided
for the application by the applicant for
the ensuites it's an except expectation
of modern living
and that in
any case um even if natural ventilation
couldn't be
provided for the bathrooms because they
would now be internal
building control would require
mechanical ventilation anyway
as has been mentioned there are
examples of offer
on
ufo on suites within other flats in the
terrace
these have been considered but they are
a dif a different historic layout
and they have compr excuse me are
largely historic consents
and they're not considered to be
um
a good comparison to this application
and it's not considered that
just because something's been done in
enough of property
it applies to this property so it's not
a precedent
and officers do consider that these
bathrooms are harmful
sorry the creation of the ensuites
and the subdivision of the historic
fabric is harmful
so
as has been mentioned the works proposed
sorry are the same as what has been
previously
considered and
refused
they the works do are not considered to
preserve or enhance the list of
buildings so that's the creation of the
ensuites the fireplaces being considered
to be acceptable
again officers consider the benefits
from the proposal are private and do not
outweigh the harm to the listed building
as required as the test
when considered against the test of the
mppf
and they're not necessary to secure the
optimum use of the building as a
residential accommodation you could
occupy
a flat there without having to have an
ensuite
bathroom
and the works are
therefore considered contrary to
national and local policy and the
recommendation is for refusal
uh thank you annabelle sorry sorry i
forgot to mention just to reiterate that
all the other works are considered
um
sorry the listed building consi
application also considers all the works
we've just looked at in the fall so the
basement window being changed
the flues
being added
um the balustrading
repairs and redevelopment
the door entry system and the roof
lights
but the officer recommendation is for
refusal
uh thank you annabelle i moved the
officers recommendations you just heard
be adopted please vice chair
a second
oh second nature thank you council
common cook members you wish to speak
council heart
thank you chair um
the room that's being subdivided one
assumes it was a bathroom
um if not where was the bathroom
yeah so it was a bathroom so
realistically you're gonna have the same
amount of waste whether it's two rooms
or one room because if you're gonna have
a show you can have a shower now or
you're gonna have it um later on in one
bathroom i don't see what difference it
actually makes the same amount of waste
is waste um i can't see
the justification for refusal okay
you're going to cut a hole in the wall
but this is the 21st century let's get
real let's just get
people living in a nice area and in a
nice place i i just don't understand how
you
what the difference is maybe i'm being
stupid maybe i just am i mean i really
don't know but i mean if um you've got
to cut a hole in a wall well i don't
think that's a major problem it's not
seen from the outside it's not like
you're making a dramatic difference to
the front of elevation
or the rear elevation and if you're
going to have a shower whether you have
a shower in your own suite or you have
it a big bathroom it makes no difference
the same amount of waste it's still
waste water
and
you know
i i'm just baffled really that you
refuse things like this i'm
beyond redempti just confused really
thank you thank you council heart i
didn't say you were stupid did i
that's a terrible
um i'm
i'm going to bring back uh and just to
comment on what you've mentioned um so
the the concern that we're raising
um is
in all of these areas it's the
subdivision of the space so when looking
at a list of building consent it's an
important consideration to look at the
internal layout and the way that the
space is laid out and has been laid out
historically
and any concerns about
in this instance it's i suppose the
creation of an additional opening into
the wall of the bedroom to create a door
into the new bathroom
but it's also the actual insertion of a
wall through the space itself as well
it isn't anything to do with the amount
of waste water that's created it's the
physical incursions to change the
character of the listed building that's
the that's the concern that we're
raising
we'll just have to check if we've got
the plans i mean if you
if
if we'll come back on that after the
debate if that's okay in terms of
obviously it's half of what was there so
you can see on the if you if you look on
the
nick the master
you can see with the hopefully the big
mouse you can see um the areas that
we're talking about here on um
effectively from the insertion and if i
click through it should uh
also show the third floor plan there we
go um
it's in a bit more detail so you can see
where we're talking about it's here in
each of the the units um in this this
space here
um
the the guidance is quite clear about
the justification for incursion
internally to create you know to put new
walls into into a listed building
obviously in this instance
um
because there is an internal change
um it's slightly different from the last
consideration in the sense of um
officer's view is that there is harm to
the listed building by virtue of this
incursion because it simply wasn't a
wall that was there it's not historic
layout it's not a wall that was ever
there so there is harm the question is
whether or not members outweigh that
harm by according to the mppf test in
202
is whether or not the public benefits of
providing these accommodation this
accommodation as they've shown outweigh
that harm
and so that's that's the issue there so
it's um
you know it's very clear there is an
incursion uh and it's just whether or
not so the points have been raised about
precedent
is again
it's a different building we've gone
through the cases that have been
mentioned it's a different layout it
doesn't have the incursions in the same
way this does we do consider this stands
on its own as a consideration um for
this application um but that's yeah
that's why we put forward the
recommendation we have but we'll see if
we can come back to you on the precise
size of those two bathrooms if we can
uh thank you ian cuz robin
yeah thank you chair uh just kind of
back on what he was just saying i think
you know this is this is the the
difficulty we've listed buildings
um
you know these listed buildings
had lav and plaster on the walls
they ain't got it now
and it's accepted that plasterboard is
is acceptable in listed buildings to a
certain degree and we certainly wouldn't
all right i know but you you can't
you're not
would we ask would we really ask a
building of this size to have all other
than plaster put back if it was if it
was damaged
destroyed
i take it um the the
uh
that the ensuite the added wall
or walls i take it's the side wall when
that across
i'll take it to b
the added wall is that wall it's just
across okay i'll take that's a stud wall
so
stud wall in itself so that's a wooden
frame with bit stud work on it and uh
and and again
you consider that not to be a permanent
feature of that building so at some that
that could be taken out sometime in the
future and returned to its norm to its
current thing i just think again i'm
just you know i'm with councillor heart
on this one um you know
you know i'm probably just as stupid as
he is but
um
you know we are in
2022 21st century
people where and
i'm not talking about the money that's
been spent on this but the from what
i've seen from the pictures and what
i've seen from the external photographs
that the quality of work that's taken
place and as someone said earlier the uh
the i think it might have been
uh
councillor rogers about the uh
the woodwork that's been put in it's in
the the uh the quality of that the
quality of the
of the fireplaces
that have
been put in and will be put in i think
we've got to take all of that into
consideration an amount of
restoration that has been done on this
building
and um
i personally i
i can't support this refusal chair sorry
i just can't support it thank you
thank you council auburn i have got you
down cancer wing and you wish to come
back off it's just on the point about
permanent change obviously what's being
proposed is a permanent change it's not
whilst i accept we're saying that it's a
stud wall that means that in the future
it could come out that is obviously it's
proposed to put a wall in there it's
there's no requirement we would have no
ability to ask the wall to come out
after we've granted permission for it so
i take your point it's a different
material from the main walls but it's a
permanent change to the internal out
thank you
councilwing
thank you chair i mean i had the
privilege of living in a grade two list
building on the paragon and
it had all its original features
very often with these listed buildings
including this one they've been
absolutely brutalized and a lot of the
original features were ripped out before
before the conservation area appeared so
first of all i'd like to congratulate
the the developer on trying to get those
original fireplaces or or alike original
fireplaces back in and the three
different match uh the similar ones
original ones that i had in my house
i do think if we're going to preserve
our historic buildings we have to
recognize that we live in the the we
live in a modern era
and if we don't allow these [ __ ] their
slight changes on a big building uh then
we will find these buildings falling
into disrepair like this building was
it's also a building i walk past on a
daily daily basis with no developers
wanting to take them on and and they
fall into disrepair they they get they
get knocked down and we totally lose our
historic buildings so i can't support
this either because i think this is a
this is a sort of a compromise to
actually refurbishing one of our most
fabulous
blocks of buildings in in a way which
enables
the building to be preserved
almost entirely
but allows modern living so i i also
can't support the motion
uh thank you for that counselor when
cancer clinton
thank you um i'm also mindful of uh
actually supporting this application
there was a couple of things i wanted to
check picking up i think um from
councillor hart which i often seem to do
the size of the bathrooms um what are we
are we losing baths and gaining two
showers um and
yeah that was the question really is
about what is what is the layout and i
can see a little bit of it but i'm not
my eyes are squinting and i can't
clearly see
in terms of size of the bathroom
as it was without the subdivision it was
eight square meters
um the bathroom
that's then created it splits it in
essentially in half so they become four
square meters each
um it appears from the drawing that the
bathroom the family bathroom which is
the top bits
of that
would have
it's showing a bath and sink and toilet
and a shower
in the ensuite with the sink in the
toilet
okay
i shouldn't let you speak really if you
if you don't mind but thank you cancer
over it
yeah i i just thought to add a little
bit of balance um
i just like to remind members that we
make the decisions here
um and i think it's entirely appropriate
that the officers bring their
professional judgment in relation to
these listed building applications
and i've listened to what's been said
and i can understand the argument that's
been put by the officers and i can
understand the argument's been put by
members but i don't think we should be
in any sense giving the impression that
we don't want to hear the professional
view of the officers because we don't
agree with it you know we absolutely
want to hear it we want them to do their
job and then we'll make the decision and
if as it seems to be the case in this
this example we don't agree with them
then we'll decide in that way but i
think it's entirely appropriate we have
this debate and this shouldn't be seen
at all as us
the officers shouldn't bring forward
these views because they should
thank you
thank you very much for that
counselor of it i totally agree and yeah
thank you uh
council more
yes thank you chair um so for what i've
seen so far the rehabilitation of this
building has been done in a very subtle
way and some of the things have had to
be done to facilitate modern living
which we've all agreed upon
that large bathroom has now been split
into two bathrooms by stud work it's
internal it's not going to be visibly
seen i appreciate what the officers have
said and i totally agree with what
council sir everett has just said as
well we're not here to them in assets to
take on board what you're saying and
then give our view i think this is a
subtle change i think it's a modern day
living for a two-bedroom property or
three-bedroom property so that the
ensuite serves one
part of the family and the smaller
bathroom serves the other bedroom uh
they will make one point that the
officer mentioned that about mechanical
ventilation that's nothing to do with
this application that's building regs
we're talking about what's put before us
and obviously that will come on board
when that goes through to fruition
and i see no reason with what they've
done so i won't be supporting the
refusal thank you
thank you councilmoor
i can't see
any other speakers
okay members i put this to you the
officer's recommendation is for refusal
those in favor
those against
abstentions
right that motion has fallen
so
please bear with me once again to come
back to you
mr liverson i presume thank you council
thompson um the
um
um obviously same issue but as i
mentioned there's slight nuance here in
terms of the actual impact itself and it
doesn't acknowledge that there is a
change
which is quantified as harm but members
have made it quite clear that it's
considered to be outweighed by the
benefits from the redevelopment of these
buildings so on that basis
the motion that we would
sort of suggest
from the discussion that's occurred
um is that members would wish to approve
um as members consider the harm
resulting from the development would be
outweighed by the public benefits from
securing the optimum viable use through
the full extent of the works
uh subject to safeguarding conditions
if the chair wishes to thank you
a proposal for
several
comes frosting
second please
thank you
and can i have a vote on that please do
you agree
any disagree
okay
any obsessions
thank you very much a good debate thank
you members for that thank you
that concludes public speaking for this
evening
um
i think counselor wing
thank you councillor wing
[Music]
thank you members of the public
okay i will now call upon el clarke
to read out the remaining planning
applications as usual if a member wishes
to reserve an application
please could they
shout at me and
you'll have your say but uh
stephen thank you
ao1
53-57 high street margate
a02
four down barton farm cottages down
barton road saint nicholas at wait
a 03 saint nicholas tavern
sorry saint lawrence tavern high street
st lawrence ramsgate
ao6 waybank way hill minster ramsgate
r09 53 addington street rams game
uh thank you very much
okay so
we're moving to well i will propose that
those that haven't been called
um
and could i have a second to please are
those a application
okay
members agree
thank you
so moving on again to item
802 for down barton
farm cottages
called my counselor right
getting me confused
sorry we missed the call-in on our side
of things so we're just now getting the
presentation ready apologies we
we missed that sorry
sorry i i
apologize
um
yes
i knew this meat was going to be tricky
um
i believe she may have actually left
she
[Laughter]
shall we have a short adjournment and if
cancer wing wishes to join for this
particular item then that is that is
fine because she's not
influencing members
i will explain we have two members of
the public in the gallery it's not
always like this
okay i can assure you
well especially when you're concerned
counselor alban that's uh
welcome back members uh
a short interview i hope you interlude
hope you enjoyed the adverts
uh can hand over to
emma
annabelle right
we're all going stupid here tonight
councillor hulk
thank you chair
so this is the application site um
this is four down barton road and this
is the applications i outlined in red
and it's an application full application
for
change of views from agricultural land
to residential garden association with
number four down barton cottages
sorry dan barton farm cottages
um so this is the application site
that's number four here
this is the side access to that dwelling
and this is the land in question
um these are some views into the site
so number four would be on the left of
this image
and this is the land we're talking about
and this is a view where you can see
obviously number four there it's side
access
and the gate we just looked at in the
previous photograph
excuse me so this is what essentially
they're proposing to do
it is it'll
maintain the existing access to number
four here but change this piece of land
um to
an extension of their garden
so
um
essentially it is in the
countryside it is agricultural land as
such but
it is clear when we look at this image
here
that is a small piece of land
it's divorced and separated from the
field you can see
running to the rear and wrapping around
here
so and it
whilst it is described as agricultural
land in the application given its small
nature and it hasn't been used for
agriculture for a number of years
it doesn't it would not it's lost as
agricultural land would not
have a significant impact on the supply
of agricultural land within the district
um the public benefits of the
this piece of agricultural land given
that it's been separated off
um
from the main field and the rest of the
land that's farmed
is not considered to be um
that's important it is considered
that the loss of this land for
agriculture production is not
significantly harmful
um in terms of
character and appearance it's not
considered the use of the garden
is
likely to consider to change and impact
the character and appearance of the land
there is some concern if the applicants
were to
put buildings and other structures on
the site that there may be some impact
um from that so condition free on the
application does remove committed
development rights for them to put
buildings on
but
given that condition
officer officers of the opinion that
there isn't a significant harm from this
proposal in terms of loss of
agricultural land or impact of the use
of that land as garden land
on the character and appearance of the
area or on living conditions or on
highways so the officer recommendation
is for approval
thank you annabelle i moved the
officer's recommendation that you've
just heard could the vice chair please
second oh second nature do we have any
members wish to speak counselor heart
at the building you're referring to
cancer heart no well i don't think so no
[Music]
your other um
down in the bottom right that one there
they see your cursors on it is certainly
in their car
or is that in the field if it's in the
field is it a stable boat that then can
be converted to an airbnb or something
like that
if we look at that plan i think the
building you're referring to is
a workshop that's actually outside of
the red line application site
thank you counselor i can bring back in
once again so it doesn't change the
boundary in the local plan of the urban
confines
the point about
potential in the future for it to be for
a dwelling to be erected
that is obviously one of the reasons why
permitted development rights have been
suggested to be taken away because
obviously what you could have a
situation is is that an outbuilding is
built as it being residential garden
land so it's in relation to the house
building out building gives you a
precedent for a structure on the site
and it builds from there in terms of the
argument
there is a previous refusal which you
have seen in the report for this land
and dwelling being erected on that land
um and obviously therefore we are very
mindful of that and the potential for a
future application to come in which
would be judged in the same way because
that was based on the current sort of
landscape character area issues
um so whilst this would extend
the residential cartilage of property
number four it doesn't change the
reality that if you put a structure on
this site on this land that it would
affect the openness of the countryside
and the landscape character area but the
change of use of the land itself to
residential land may mean that you get
some uh
to residential paraphernalia that's not
doesn't require planning permission
doesn't have you know it's not a
building with a structure it's i don't
know children's play equipment or
whatever it is um
but
we've removed the pd rights to avoid
structures that could affect the
landscape character area uh on the
scheme thank you
thank you
whatever sorry
um
the condition is in force if permission
is granted um it is in force on that
land from then on if the condition were
to be breached then the condition would
have to be breached for 10 years
before it would become lawful and
obviously if it was breached then the
council would consider it under its
enforcement procedures
thank you council forever
yeah i just wonder
and miss limits has partly answered the
question perhaps but i mean what benefit
do
the people of number four get from
changing it from agricultural to a
garden what is it they can do in the
garden that they can't do on
agricultural land which is not being
used as agricultural land at the moment
and for example if they were to put up a
child swing in the middle of it at the
moment it seems extremely unlikely to me
that the council will take enforcement
action
um so obviously
i mean technically if that land was used
now without permission in place
then the use would be related to the
residential use rather than as
agricultural use so technically that
would be a breach of planning control on
that basis um
just to clarify a child's swing wouldn't
be operational development and therefore
it wouldn't need planning permission but
um in terms of benefit to be accrued
from it i suppose the the logic and
again this is me not knowing the
motivation of an applicant which
obviously isn't a consideration but
clearly this uh i suppose tidies up
the the land holding the what relates to
what that they that that person owns but
again
the motivation for the application isn't
something that can be considered what we
have to consider though is
what the in what the outcomes could be
from the permission which is why we've
removed the condition or put the
condition on to move pd
a building
is
a shed a garage a stable
a caravan isn't is it because it has
wheels and is movable so as long as you
have two wheels on it it's a movable
structure so therefore it doesn't need
planning is that correct
and if so
then you could do that on agricultural
but you could do that in your garden so
therefore again it could become an
airbnb by putting a uh shepherd's hut up
there or whatever you want to call it
these days a glamping site or whatever
so just sorry we just need a bit of
clarification on this really in i think
okay so
the the question of whether or not a
caravan could be cited on there um
obviously would relate to whether or not
it's operational development or not
and under the planning act and when i
say operational development that's a
consideration as to whether or not um
it is uh
it hits the definition of development
under the planet so it's about whether
or not the structure itself is permanent
how it's fixed the land and a number of
considerations like that in terms of a
caravan obviously if a caravan is cited
somewhere it may not need planning
permission if that caravan though is
cited for the purpose of renting out
that caravan
then there is no permitted development
rights for the situation for a use that
is not connected with the dwelling house
if you're renting out accommodation so
there is a change of use of the land
from residential garden land to the
siting of a caravan for tourist use
whatever however would refer to it so
there are safeguards within the planning
act to avoid in outcomes such as that
occurring
and we've considered that the rights
we've taken away are sufficient to deal
with one potential issue other potential
outcomes
um are i suppose part and parcel of
what's in the planning act and whether
or not it results in something that
needs planning permission or not and
whether or not then we get an
application in and could consider it or
not
thank you councilman right okay thank
you um uh thank you for that mr
livingston um michael might you've kind
of answered all my my concerns um i've
got i suppose i because it was my ward
once upon a time the the in in saint
nicholas they are really worried at the
moment because their village seems to be
disappearing with all the the impact of
all the building work that's going on
and
just wanted to make sure that this isn't
going to be another
development by stealth
as it has been as it has been in the
past
thank you councillor wright i think you
understand what you're saying there but
i don't think you know that isn't the
case at the moment council clinton
yeah thank you i um i just wanted to
i do find it strange that someone would
suddenly want a garden that enormous um
unless you are i suppose already in an
enormous house with an enormous garden
but then that's not my life
um
but i noticed that there are some
plantings and stuff i just wondered
whether or not there was any intention
to enclose it
um and if not i suppose rather than
airbnb i have visions of marquis and
garden parties and wedding receptions
and things like that but
that comes back to the intended use
which would concern me
yeah
so
it's the same issue as to whether or not
there would be a change used to land if
those sorts of events were to occur so
it's not about the physical structures
it's about the use of the land and
whether or not there's
too many of those events in a year and
again this is all hypothetical on this
in terms of the point you're raising my
enclosure of the land
um the particular permitted development
rights that exist right now on the site
allow for a two meter fence to be
erected around that site you know close
boarded potentially
um because it's
as i'm gonna just quickly look across to
my other offices to make sure i'm not
saying anything that's wrong there no
they're not telling me i'm wrong so
that's fine
so
on that basis because
it's it's not next to a highway it's not
directly adjoining a highway which would
mean it needs to be a meter now again
um
the issue is more about
uh structures being placed in there
which is why we've controlled it in the
way that we have but um
you know in in in those terms
again it comes back to the point about
what the planning act kind of covers
anyway and what other pd would cover
in the event that stuff happened on the
site i think the reality is we don't
know what will happen on the site
members can't take account of what could
happen
but obviously we are aware of the
concerns of members i think that's been
made very clear by this particular
development and therefore we will
certainly
be making sure that we are aware of
anything that occurs on that site you
know and i will flag this up with
planning enforcement in terms of the
concerns about anything that could
anything that breaches
planning can you know planning control
thank you
uh thank you ian
okay i can't see any other speakers
there so i put this to you members those
in favor of this application please show
those against
abstentions
that looks to me as if it's carried
i will
check stephen
yes that's been carried thank you
members
i would ask councillor wing to have a
walkies around market again if she would
please
thanks
thank you members um
bringing you to item
r09 which is 53 edington street ramsgate
we don't have any speakers obviously so
the report
is with
emma thank you
okay the application site is in this
area here outlined in red fronts onto
addington street and to the rear of the
plot is spencer place
and this is an aerial view so the
application site is this plot here so
you can see there's already um built
form to the rear this is a single story
out building there's already single
story extensions to the rear of the of
the plot
um
this property um number 55 you can see
they've got a
quite a deep two-story rear extension
running along the boundary here
and this is number 51
and the rear number 51 is number 51a so
this is a separate um dwelling to the
rear of number 51 so two dwellings
within this plot
and then this is a
little bit blurry i'm afraid but a more
detailed um view looking at the
application site so this is the
application property here
and these you can see your existing
structures to the rear and again you can
see the
number 51a an existing dwelling and
that's the
extension linked with number 51a and
then number 51 in this location here and
again you can now see the extension
projecting from number 55.
um you could also see this
in this um
visual image the spencer place to the
rear and you can see here these are the
rear gardens um associated
with
um
spencer
square this is the front elevation of
the property so there's
um the only alterations to the front is
that some metal railings are being
installed along the front boundary so
the metal railings will match the
properties either side so there's no
real concerns with the impact from the
front elevation and that's that's the
only change there
um and then this i'm now going to go
through some photos from the rear so i'm
going to start with some photos from
number 53 and then i'll show you um
within this rear area of number 51 and
51a
so um this is at the rear numbers uh
from spencer
place looking towards the application
site so this is the application site on
the right hand side here so this is an
existing
structure to the rear single story you
can see there's these are the other
single story structures um as well
behind the property this is number 51a
so separate dwelling that fronts onto
spencer place
and here again you can see the extension
that projects out from the neighbourhood
property
slightly more zoomed in so again you can
see the existing structures to the rear
of the application property and so
there's pretty much a single story
extension almost a full depth of the
plot other than in this location here
where there's a small yard area that
serves the property as external amenity
space
and then a bit more of a zoomed in view
of the structures so they've got sort of
butterfly style roofs at the rear and
this here on the right-hand side again
is that open yard area
so this is now taken from inside the
application property looking from the
first floor window out towards the rear
so this is the existing rear extensions
to the rear of the property that is the
existing um building that's on the rear
boundary of the property again you can
see the rear extension of number 55 to
the left and you can start to see
the side elevation of number 51a on the
right hand side here
this is taken inside the
internal yard area serving the
application property so this is the only
current um external multi-space serving
the property so this is between the
existing rear extension and the far
outbuilding on the rear boundary and
again you can see the side first of all
window of number 51a
in this location here and you can see
some existing ground floor windows
serving 51a
this is just looking up at that
two-story um rear projection from number
55 so you can see it's just a blank wall
you can see
the depth of that extension and again
this is within that yard area between
the two existing extensions within the
application site
and now i'm going to show you some a
view and taken along um from this area
here so
there's a yard area that serves number
51 in this location here so that's their
immunity space and then the mean
immediate space for number 51 a is in
this location here
so this is looking towards number 51a
there's a first floor window which
serves a bathroom
there's two ground floor windows that
serve a
kitchen and dining room space and this
area here is the kitchen as well and
that's a door serving that kitchen space
so this isn't considered to be a
habitable room because given the size of
this space and these windows are
secondary windows serving one large open
plan space within the ground floor of
the building
so this is taken from the rear from
spencer place
looking back towards the side view of
number 51 a so again this is um the
window serving what i believe we've
looked at some plans that they recently
submitted for an application so that's
what it shows on the plan so i'm
assuming this is they are correct um but
this is a secondary window serving the
lounge area again you can see the
bathroom window in this location here so
the distance between this side wall and
the um side boundary is one and a half
meters
so this is that their amenity space
serving the property so you can see a
table and chairs
in this location here not particularly
wide space
and then as we approach the rear of
number 51
you can see
a door and window this serves the
lounge area this is a bedroom window
first floor level here and there's also
a basement window so you can see this
basement window here that serves a play
area
and so you can see there's a step
leading up to that door
so these two windows are serving serving
the lounge space and you can say this is
the immediate space serving that
property so you can see some
play equipment in that space
and this is taken on those steps where
the door is looking back towards spencer
place so again you can see the side
elevation number 51a and this is their
kitchen extension and the kitchen door
in this location
so
this is the existing front elevation
and this is the proposed so you can see
the only change being the metal range at
the um and on the front boundary which
as i said we have no concerns we've
given the facts they match the design
and materials of neighboring properties
and this is the existing rear elevation
so you can see the existing rear
projections at single story level
and this is a proposal so the proposal
is for a first floor extension that
extends out above
part of the existing ground floor
extension
it also includes a walkway that leads to
a roof terrace that's being created
above the rear outbuilding on the rear
boundary
so in terms of materials the site's
located in the conservation area so they
have used um timber windows and doors
and um
cladding has been used which is there's
um presence of some cladding in the in
the surrounding area so there's no
concerns with the actual material
of the
extension
in terms of the actual presence of the
extension in terms of the impact on the
conservation area whilst it's quite deep
so the actual depth of the extension is
5.58 metres
given the fact that there is this
two-story um projection at number 55
this doesn't come out as deep as that
two-story projection so in terms of the
actual
impact on the character appearance of
the conservation area from the principle
of a first floor extension we don't have
any concerns
so
this is just again to show you the
context of that so the first extension
is coming out this point here
it extends um to roughly this point here
so it isn't as deep at this point so
again you can see quite a good setback
from the rear elevation of that
extension and spencer place and
obviously we've got the projection of
number 51a on this side here so again as
as as i've said there's no concern with
the visual impact of that first floor
extension
so this is the existing side elevation
so this faces the amenity space serving
number 51 and 51a so this is the current
view that
they have of the projections that come
out at a single story level and this
area here was the external yard space
and this is now the proposed extension
and side view that they would get so you
can see the raised ease level
at this point here you can see the depth
of the extension
so number um
53
already projects one meter beyond the
rear elevation of number 51 so there's
already that projection beyond that
property and then on top of that there's
now the 5.58 meter deep extension so
overall there's going to be a depth
of um six and a half meters from the
existing rear elevation of number 51.
you can see that there's this walkway
area here and then this is the roof
terrace over the existing rear
outbuilding so the roof terrace has
railings around it there's no solid
enclosures
and this will be clearly visible from
spencer place to the rear um which is
basically on the boundary with
centreplace at this point here
so in terms of the floor plans these are
the existing floor plans so you can see
the
projection at ground floor level of the
extension
and now these are the proposed floor
plans so
the main plan to look at really is the
first floor plan in which is this one
here so this is the extension
at first floor level so you can see the
depth of the extension which serves a
bedroom
and a balcony area
this balcony area
will be inset behind this side wall so
there won't be any direct overlooking
from this balcony down into the
properties but there will be
views out at this point here and as you
saw number 51 is located in this in this
area here only 1.5 meters from the
boundary with side windows so there
would potentially be some um indirect
overlooking from this balcony area
towards the side elevation of number 51.
you can see here the flat roof of
the
existing outbuilding the rear and all of
this area is proposed to be turned into
a roof terrace so this all will be a
seating space
so you can see the existing courtyard
area serving
the property so there's you can see the
ground floor level here and the views
down to it at first or level so at this
point that courtyard is covered so the
only exposed space would be this area
here and you can see in terms of the
size of the flat roof terrace this will
obviously become the main amenity space
serving the property because
it's much larger than the existing
courtyard area and is at first full
level
this is the
rear projection at the the existing rear
outbuilding right at the back of the
site on the boundary and again here you
can see more detail the proposed roof
terrace
um above that space and the railings
proposed around that
so the concerns
we have are to do with the
um
the visual impact of the roof terrace
and the impact that has on the current
appearance of the area
so
just going back sorry to this view here
as you can see this this the roof
terrace at this point here if this is
has railings above it is going to be
extremely visible from spencer place it
is a conservation area we have to look
at whether this fits in with with the
character of the area is sympathetic to
the historic carrots of the area
we consider that this will be an alien
feature on the rear of this property um
whilst you may consider it's just
railings on top of the roof it's the
associated use with those railings so
this is going to be a seating space so
you can imagine that this is going to
have tables and chairs on top of it
could have a parasol on top of it
and
it's considered the use of that for that
purpose and the associated range with it
would be detrimental to the character of
the area because it's not characteristic
of the rear of properties in this
location
so that is one concern that we have
um is the impact of that on on the
conservation area um as an alien feature
and that just detracts from the visual
images of the area
the other concerns we have to do the
impact on neighboring living conditions
so
just going back to um
the neighboring properties so
in terms of the side elevation of number
51a as i said this is a bathroom window
and a ground floor level of secondary
windows so we don't actually consider
that there would be a significant impact
on light or outlook to those windows in
that side elevation
what we are concerned about is the um
impact from overlooking from the terrace
so again the roof terrace is in this
location here
the um balustrading around it is all at
low level see-through railings and
there's no privacy screening anywhere so
you could stand at this point here and
look directly down into this immunity
space serving number 51a which as you
can see is very restricted in size
and um
and on top of that there would be views
through to
this emily space here
so again from the roof terrace looking
back to this space that you'd be able to
look directly into this space also into
these windows here and this is a lounge
window and you've got a bedroom window
here at first for a level so again in
terms of the those distances and that
relationship there is there is
significant concern with the impact on
their privacy
in addition to that in terms of
the
property to the rear
so this is the rear garden of
number
24 spencer square
there's a distance of only 4.36 meters
between this rear elevation of number 24
and the proposed roof terrace so again
at this point here someone could be
standing here looking directly into this
rear immunity space so again direct
overlooking
very
short distance
and significant loss of privacy for that
rear garden
also there will be some indirect
overlooking of of the neighbouring
properties gardens as well in this
location which also
quite a short distance from from that
roof terrace
so the roof terrace causes us concerns
because of the significant overlooking
to all properties in the surrounding
area from that space which we consider
will be quite intensely used given the
size of that space in comparison to the
existing immune space serving the
property
and the other concern we have is with
the actual first floor rear extension
and the impact that has on the rear
elevation of number 51
so
as you can see again on this first floor
plan this is the depth of the extension
so as i said it's 6.5 meters
beyond that existing rear elevation of
number 51.
the as you saw from the
side elevation this is the increase in
height from the existing single-story
projection up to um two-story levels so
there's going to be
this high ease level at two story at 6.5
meters depth running along on the
boundary
so the concern we have is that this will
impact on light and outlook to the rear
windows within number 51
whilst also creating a sense of
enclosure for the immunity space serving
number 51 and part of the immunity space
serving number 51a
and when looking at it again from the
from this view here you can see in terms
of the impact on light so there is that
two-story projection from number 55
which obviously causes some loss of
light already but in terms of this
extension here at the point where the
sun is coming around to the south it
would be causing um
lots of light and outlook through to
this space which already as you can see
because of the presence of number 51 so
the rear is already very restricted in
terms of light and outlook anyway
and so that is another concern that we
have
so um
oh the other point we have is to do with
again going back to the roof terrace is
the use of this terrace and the
potential impact from um noise and
disturbance on the neighboring occupiers
so in this location here again if that's
going to be used as a main immediate
space serving the property we have
tables and chairs there's no restriction
on the hours of use of this space this
here is a front bedroom window it's a
number 51 a
so in terms of the distance again it's
about two meters or so from a bedroom
window to this roof terrace where there
could be noise and disturbance
again in terms of the impact on existing
windows in the rear of number 51 even
though it's slightly further away we
still consider that a first full level
which is level with bedroom windows that
the use of this terrace would impact on
the living conditions of these occupiers
in terms of noise and disturbance from
that that use
so it is recommended for refusal on the
grounds of the visual impact of the roof
terrace and the use of that space on the
character appearance of the conservation
area
the impact of the first floor rear
extent extension on the
light and outlook of number 51 and
causing a sensor enclosure to that space
and the use of the roof terrace and the
impact on a number of surrounding
properties in terms of loss of privacy
and noise and disturbance from that use
thank you
thank you emma i moved the officer's
recommendation which you heard is for
refusal with vice chair please second oh
second nature thank you councillor
common cook um cancer austin
thank you chair
uh and thank you officers for for your
report um
this is um an area is in my ward and
it's an area with a variety of mixed
very close together housing
as you've seen
this is a property that is
is the smallest house in the street it's
tiny it's like a doll's house overlooked
by enormous buildings that are like
warehouses so if there had been previous
uh concerns as we've seen before if we
had a conservation area and all the
associated uh concerns about that
previously perhaps this wouldn't have
have developed in the way it has because
this is the property that is overlooked
massively by all the the neighboring
properties yes i can see that there may
be some concerns on the other hand the
neighbours
the uh houses at the back nobody has
raised an objection there have been no
objections whatever lodged to this
proposal
ramsgate town council has looked at this
is its planning committee we raised no
objections heritage and design forum has
raised no objections
as a ward councillor i know that um
residents in central harbour ward are
not backward in coming forward if
they're not happy with something quite
rightly and nobody has raised any
objection
um with regard to
the having the garden area uh the roof
terrace the first floor this is a
feature of a number of uh houses in that
immediate area
so it's not um a precedent i can see
that there may be concerns about it but
with regard to the potential for noise
this house is two doors down from a pub
uh thank you councillor austin council
heart
thank you chad i seem to have spoken on
everything tonight um
this is a difficult one because i don't
know if councillor wing is a party
animal or not um i don't know that well
um but i do have
concerns
that
the balous trading is not
shall we say privacy-minded and i think
that's the biggest issue with that i
think it should go back and it should be
offered
um that a screen goes up at a height
that if you're sitting in a chair or
at least we had this before in another
building where they were overlooking a
kitchen and they put a a good height
barrier in there and i think it has to
be done in a way that gives privacy to
the neighbors and i think that's quite
important and um
you know if you want open space and you
don't need the outputting then you can
knock the outbuilding down and have your
outside space so that that's an
immaterial argument um but i think the
issue i have is the fact that you do
lose privacy um with the fact that it's
it's on it's on a flat roof and i think
you've got to have a privacy screen in
there and i think that's quite important
thank you chair
uh thank you
i'm going to bring emma back just on
that subject remember
um well
the concern we would have with that i
can understand what you're saying yes
normally in normal circumstances if
there's a balcony or roof terrace that
is overlooking we would encourage some
form of privacy screening obviously in
this instance you have to consider what
visual impact that would have from
increased screening in this location
so we would normally expect in order to
protect privacy a screen of
approximately 1.7 meters in height so if
you had a screen that wrapped around
because there's obviously views from
every direction from this roof terrace
that are causing overlooking concerns so
this
rear elevation and the side elevation
and potentially back in looking towards
the the rear elevation of number 51 so
you'd actually need it on almost every
side of the roof terrace and it's the
resulting visual impact that would have
given the fact this is a conservation
area so it's not going to look
in keeping with the area
that's hot
thank you i'm not trying to be obtuse or
awkward as you know me um but
that screen would be no higher than the
building next to it
yes so if you please one at a time
please if you take the pitch of that
roof if you put a screen on top of that
because they're obviously going to level
off that route because you can't have a
a sloping um
should we say terrace or patio i don't
mind what you call it but that that is a
sloping roof um so that's either going
to go up or it's going to come down if
they wanted if they were minded to bring
it down a bit that would stop
the
overall height of it but it's still not
going to go above the pitch of that roof
so i can't see what the objection to
that is and i do understand what you're
saying with regards to
lack of light in those little terraces
next door etc etc now
um i do agree with councillor austin
that is a tiny property in the middle of
some enormous buildings and it is quite
quite shocking how tall they are and if
probably if she put in the right
permissions you probably get it up to
that roof height and then carry on that
way so that's a different that's a
different thing altogether however
i do think screening would be an
essential part of this and i think to
refuse it outright
i think is wrong i think it needs to go
back to the drawing board and it has to
be done in a way which is sympathetic to
your wishes now if that means that
that's obviously a yellow stock or red
stock brick if that was then built up to
hide
that
overall increase in height like that
building is there then that surely
wouldn't produce an objection on that
side so that's something to consider
maybe i don't know thank you thank you
counselor we've got to look at what
we've got tonight i think
i know you understand that council
reverend
yeah i think we've got to be very
careful here not to talk about the
applicant because what we're what we're
being asked to do is give permission for
something which could be sold on and
used by a completely different person in
the future who might use it in a
completely different way so
i think the applicant has to be
irrelevant um i just wonder whether um
i'd just like to know about that that
store building really because it seems
to me that the property obviously is
deficient in outside space and it's
entirely reasonable to try and create
that outside space but by creating a
first floor level that's where we're
running into a problem so um can you
tell me any more about that building i
mean could it for example be demolished
with or without planning consent in
order to create some outside space which
obviously wouldn't create the
overlooking problem
so this is the um
the existing floor plan so you can see
this is this this is the store area here
so
yes if that was demolished then the
whole of this space would be potential
external media space to serve the
building
um this structure is too small to
require any form of permission to be
demolished so it could be demolished i
don't think we'd have any huge concerns
with with that being demolished so yes
that would be
a solution for achieving external
immunity space to serve the property
that wouldn't be impacting on the
neighbouring properties
if i can just come back as well whilst
i'm speaking
on the point it was just raised again
about the
potential screening
what you need to consider is whilst yes
you could in theory build this up with
brick and you could say well that's
actually in keeping what's around here
because you've got a building here up to
ease level with brick and you can see
other properties here you have to
consider that in this particular
circumstances there is a dwelling here
that has a side elevation front in the
space that's only 1.5 meters away from
this wall
at the moment it has
these two ground floor side elevation
windows that are serving a lounge area
and whilst i have said the secondary
windows you can see from the front here
there's a very small window to the front
serving that space as well so probably
the main light is actually
probably from these side windows that
are much larger if you build up at this
point here with another 1.78 meter high
structure again it's the resulting
impact that's also going to be still
having on light and outlook into this
property because this is the only
immunity space serving this property to
the side and there is a lot of light and
outlook currently probably coming to
this property above this at single story
level so i think we just have to be
careful that you know one solution
creates potentially another problem so
thank you very much council austin you
come back um chair i wonder i don't i
know there are regulations um uh that
govern this and i'm not sure if it's
appropriate to suggest that you might be
minded to arrange a site visit um
because actually i think until members
see
quite how uh this this whole space is
laid out i think it's quite difficult to
envisage even from the from the plans
and and the and the photographs
thank you i will see if there's any more
cancer more
yes thank you chair um i think the main
points that that stick out are the fact
that there is loss of light to 51a
and 51.
the fact that you're having that roof
terraced area means they can overlook
51a 51
the people in spencer
square
um there's no sufficient screening and i
think as council everett said you know
if that rear stall was removed they
would have an adequate rear garden at
ground floor level which wouldn't would
would still impact if they were noisy
because they were in close proximity but
it would would reduce the overlooking
which is the biggest issue there um so
that's the concerns i have with this
thank you chair thank you councilmoor
uh council auckland
yeah thank you chair um
yeah as uh has been said it's it's a
difficult one but
um the extension in itself
uh
attached the house seems
fine it is
it is
the actual
sighting of uh
of a terrorist with that on there and uh
um
i think it would look odd
i know i know what council russia said
but i do think it would look odd
and
i'm just slightly swayed in favor of the
officer recommendation thank you jen
uh thank you for that council robin um
councilman zesky
yeah chad
i'm inclined to agree with the my other
councillors
on
the extension itself being good and no
problem with that it's the flat roof um
terrace that seems to be the issue maybe
a site visit could be um a good idea so
i'd leave that in new orleans chair as
to whether or not we can do that thank
you
thank you member council common cook
thank you chair i'll take on board what
i said about screen
but the screen is only one side isn't it
what happens the people in spencer
square opposite
they're still overlooked the people to
the other side are overlooked if you had
screens going all the way around that
sort of defeats the object doesn't it
so in my mind
i'd i'd support the officer's view thank
you
thank you council como
canta crinden
um just picking up on what was said
earlier about um
you
we know
what we're agreeing here or not
but you don't know what's going to
happen 10 20 years down the line we
could have screens put up but they could
be removed by later
um
people in the properties and i too am
worried about the the overlooking
impact
uh thank you um
no i can't see any other members now i
know it's been touched on regarding the
site visit but i feel
what i've heard from you members is that
um
you are on the officer's side
for
refusal on this so take on board what's
been said about
this space at the back and so forth but
um
so therefore i am going to
put the officer's recommendation
to you which is for refusal
um so those who agree with the officers
really please show their hands
those against
any abstentions
one thank you
uh that has
officer's recommendation has been
carried for refusal
thank you members
thank you again for
very good debate tonight